so i am very thankful for mba for giving
me this huge platform worldwide but
if they're going to do something
wrong i'm going to expose them
when should professional athletes feel
morally obligated to put their careers
their personal safety and their own
freedom on the line to speak out about
political injustice raised in turkey
anna's cantor freedom decided to use his
fame to speak out about the issues that
matter most while we are dribbling the
ball
on the other side of the world people
are losing their loved ones in their
lives and losing their hopes freedom
made headlines earlier this year for
criticizing the national basketball
association and its biggest stars for
their business relationships with china
which has been accused of violating the
civil rights of ethnic muslims known as
the leaguers and forcing them into
re-education camps reason caught up with
freedom to talk about his early
childhood growing up in turkey as a
basketball prodigy calls for his arrest
and what's driving his activism
[Music]